all right I think we can get started
thanks everyone for showing up for the
last talk of the day I expected it to be
half empty in here and everyone to be
tired so thanks for still coming so if
your career in software development
resembles mine in any way at all you've
probably found one thing to be constant
over everything else there's always more
work to do no matter how much you try no
matter how long you work there's always
something else you can do today tomorrow
next week and for me like I said this
has definitely been the case I work on
the Google cloud client libraries team
and we maintain hundreds of different
packages and to make this problem worse
they aren't even all node packages we
maintain eight different languages now
luckily no one on the team is expected
to know all eight of these languages but
almost all of us know more than one and
we still have to maintain all these
things so that only helps the problem a
little bit and what we started to
realize is that we needed help and
that's when the bots came to save us and
I say the bots came to save us but I'm
obviously speaking poetically they
didn't come to save us and our bots
aren't all that smart so I wouldn't
expect them to be our saviors I mean
they're helpful but they tend to be good
at just doing a single thing very well
and before we get further into this talk
I wanted to discuss what is a bot what
does that mean in the terms of software
development when I think about robots I
immediately think of an automotive
assembly line in these big arms that
replace the job of humans from decades
before but we really don't mean this
when we say BOTS and technology we're
not usually talking about a physical
robot of of any kind and we're not even
talking about a robots.txt robots.txt
czar crawled by web crawlers and are
fairly similar to the bots were
referring to but they're a little
different as well
what I usually mean when I say the word
BOTS is something that resembles this I
mean a script that runs as a result of
an action a trigger from something
external that might be a timer that
might be a pull request and as a
response to this event some code runs
bots aren't good at all things of course
as I said they're usually good at
repetitive work things that are scoped
one single thing but they're very good
at that one thing particularly they're
good at things that don't require
intuition or any sort of debugging so
the sort of action that can be blindly
followed with this strict process and
this isn't necessarily a bad thing these
it turns out humans are really bad at
being robots multiple studies show that
when humans encounter repeated processes
we fatigue we make mistakes we miss
steps and so it's good if we can use
something that's good at following rote
rules instead of ourselves I think it
should be our goal to eliminate as many
of those sorts of tasks as possible so
we can focus on the work that requires
human intuition and generally brings joy
to developers and while most of us use
BOTS I think it's true that the majority
of software developers haven't written
about and with any hope by the end of
this talk they'll a lot of the mystery
around that will be removed so to frame
this I want to talk a bit about levels
of automation the SAE society of
automotive engineers has a standard for
self-driving cars where they separate
the levels that they are automated the
the amount the system does work so they
separate those out so we can have an
understanding of the advancement and a
sort of risk involved this will help us
sort of understand things and it will
allow us to start with simpler BOTS and
get to more complex ones as I talk so
this is the chart they use I'm not going
to try to describe it exactly but at
level 0 it's your typical car the ones
that have been around forever the human
being does everything eventually you get
to level 5 where the machine does
everything in theory you don't
human being it is entirely unscoped
meaning it doesn't just have a list of
tasks that can do it can do infinite
tasks anything at all this is the the
fully self-driving car so if we take
that and apply it to BOTS we get this
chart we're at level one we have things
that are automated a little bit sort of
the level of a script or a tool and
eventually again we get to level five
where the Machine does everything you
can see at each level of this chart one
more thing is taken over by the system
that's the bolded bit I'm not going to
try to describe this much further here I
think it'll be easier as we go into
examples so at level one puts simply our
goal is to automate portions of our
workflow not necessarily make a bot do
all the work but take away the parts
where it's easy to make small little
mistakes as a human being you're going
to discover the work you're going to
kick off a task hit a button run a
script but the work itself will be
automated so let's put up an example we
have a package and our goal is to
release this but releasing takes
multiple actions it might involve
tagging a branch updating a release
number publishing to NPM maybe deploying
Docs etc so how do we fix that well we
can write a script the script can do all
of those things and we can click a
button this might not sound entirely
like a body yet BOTS we don't tend to
think of as being a thing where we just
actually get a script locally but this
is the most basic bot the deployment
environments your machine it does a task
for you the only thing that's a bit odd
is because at level one we're still
triggering an assisting system it
doesn't feel all that automated and then
we move on to level two the best way to
describe this is that we can automate
the discovery now as well as the work
but we're still as human beings going to
be responsible for supervising the
bottom we're not going to trust it to
operate unmonitored a representative
task for that would be that script we
authored previously could be forgotten
to be run and it would be good to know
if that happens if we have some release
ready to go let's say we've updated the
release number within package.json and
we haven't published yet it would be
cool if we had some sort of monitoring
to let us know about that so we don't
just let it sit stale forever and when
we starting the level 3 this is where I
think you start to really see them as is
very useful pots this point we let the
bots start doing work for us we have to
supervise it a little bit probably check
in on it but for the most part it's
fully starting to self monitor and we're
not going to have to do a lot of
intervention ourselves an example of how
that might manifest is we have issues in
our repository that go stale so we all
have repositories that we have to work
in and if she's gonna sign the
developers on the team but occasionally
people on the team become overloaded or
that individual and the team maybe isn't
the subject matter expert for that so
they're stalling out so we can implement
something that juggled these issues
around you could assign them to a
different team member to see if that
would help us get traction another
example you might see here is something
like a CL a bot maybe where you can
notice that someone on your team doesn't
have clas and you could sort of walk
through that it's going to require very
little limited monitoring the monitoring
at that point is mostly in the fact that
nothing's going to get merged without a
human but the bot can still go through
that entire interaction with a new
contributor and then we it's level 4 and
things get a bit more advanced we don't
really have to supervise anymore at all
the system handles its own fall back
when errors happen it knows how to self
recover maybe if it has an error can't
recover from it opens a bug for you so
what does an example like this start to
look like sometimes it turns out that in
our repositories we have branches that
get created for PRS and contributors
forget to delete them and this starts to
make things get a bit below D and hard
to see what's going on so maybe we could
write a bot that deletes them and I feel
like this is a point to mention that as
you go through the levels risk starts to
increase also this is this is a rather
risky thing to do what if those those
branches are needed and you made a
mistake in this bot this is where I mean
to say it's not really supervised
anymore it starts to take action
that would be hard to recover from so
other buffs in this category are things
that look like merging on green to
master where maybe you reviewed it
notated earlier but someone merged
something else then the CI passed and it
gets merged in and that could be rather
risky there are a lot of bucks in this
category and the example we'll use later
falls into this level four and finally
we get to level five and they get level
five the easiest way to describe it as
the boss the robot starts to become your
own boss because unlike the previous one
it's now unscoped it no longer has a
question and a solution it just responds
to all questions in all solutions and I
think you'll find the science fiction
has taught us that unschooling BOTS can
be a rather dangerous thing I don't know
that I would really want this happening
in my repository I would say we avoid
doing this altogether if at all possible
and after all human beings are good at
these sorts of tasks anyway and we
usually want to intuition so this
probably isn't where we want to look for
BOTS to sort of tie back to automotive
they're finding the same problem in
automotive driverless cars getting to
level five is going to be very difficult
because it means the automation needs to
understand new scenarios that hasn't
seen before and that's that's a pretty
giant jump from training on existing
scenarios so at this point though I
think we should talk about writing BOTS
and now we just sort of giving you quick
examples and you probably thought maybe
we could just write a bot to write the
bots let's go back to the previous step
we probably don't want to do that right
if we find a way to have BOTS write BOTS
we've probably reached century computing
and then you want them to this weird
problem of who watches the watcher
eventually realize it's Turtles all the
way down and you're probably just going
to have to accept that we're doing this
ourselves so while we can't use about to
do this for us we can leverage a series
of frameworks and our team found one
that we liked a lot called Pro bot this
is good because most of us don't want to
spend our time authoring BOTS
the bots are means to an end they're not
the solution itself to not or marketing
and so being able to leverage other
open-source products I mean we can get
back to our product and not just being
bad authors Probot integrates really
well to github as authored by a github
engineer and allows us to trigger events
in the form of small node apps based on
a github context many different github
events the nice thing too is they have a
variety of samples we can use to sort of
inspire ourselves and understand what to
do the documentation is fairly good and
so that's what we decided to go with so
the first thing we're going to want to
do is think about the scenario you want
to solve and try to scope that - a
problem that is solvable by a bot and no
longer requires a human so a simple
question that we might ask yourself is
could we have renovate PRS pen appears
from the renovate bot automatically run
CI for us and not wait for an engineer
on the team to go tell the CI system to
run the reason this is important to
systems like Travis circle and the
internal CI we use they restrict which
contributors can kick off builds and
this is important most build systems
have secrets and if any random person on
the internet can run a build they can
modify those files and they can expose
secrets so we don't know allow that just
happen it needs to be a trusted
contributor of the of the repository of
the project but renovate isn't really a
contributor it's a thing we use it's the
thing we trust but it's not part of the
github org and so we could probably
write about to do this and that seems
like a small enough size and something
direct when renovate creates a PR and we
detect that it's the author we run CI
the next thing we need to figure out is
what sort of events do we need to
trigger this on we could try to trigger
on all possible events but that's
probably going to mean it runs too much
so we might want to trigger an initial
PR maybe on updates to the PR maybe on
the creation of an issue that's probably
not relevant in this exact example but
it's a common one there are dozens of
different events you can trigger on but
for me these four are most often the
ones you end up using
in the next decision you get to make is
our bots going to alert or change your
system and this again goes back to risk
if a system only ever alerts you a
problem it's generally not that risky in
the case of something like a CLA bot or
maybe a linting bot it's likely to just
leave a comment on the PR it's not going
to merge your code not gonna run your
build system relatively safe on the
other hand if we make changes that run
the build system merge publish they
become more risky these are the sort of
things that causes incidents and so you
need to decide how much risk you're
willing to take on in this instance so
for the case of this bot we're going to
likely add a label to our repository
that says it's safe to run CI and so
this looks a little more like a change
so that's a little bit more risk but we
can't get the value without that so
let's get around to building it robot
comes with this QuickStart we can run
via npx and it's a pretty reasonable
place to start if you've never written
about before it's going to populate you
a node project that has most of the
templating after asking you some simple
questions we didn't use this exactly
because we found out that we wanted to
do templating on top of robot and so we
recently added our own bot generator
that does basically the same thing
there's a few less questions because we
can make a lot of assumptions for
instance all the authors are Google and
so that makes that a little simpler but
this also allowed us to do things like
template our read amis and have
consistent style across all of our
samples and have similar targets inside
package at JSON like I said at the end
of the day this is just another node
package all the boxes to does this runs
a method when an event happens it's a
pretty straightforward application and
looks like a lot of things you've used
before and has a very bare minimum set
of dependencies we're going to use
something from octa kit to interact with
git we're going to use Pro bot in our
case we use the thing called GCF details
because we leverage Google Cloud
functions for this and we have a package
called GS GCF details we wrote
let us do that so diving a bit deeper
into source I wanted to look at the code
that isn't just boilerplate most of this
will be you'll probably never edit it
but inside of one of the CSS files
you're going to find a function that
takes an application and on a list of
events some action in this case we have
a few different triggers that we're
going to go on if a PR is open to reopen
or synchronized that's a PR update we
want to run an event this these are all
possible options for for renovate when
it comes through but the bot we write is
pretty simple we check the pull request
user login and if they user login
matches renovate we can add a label to
the repository bots aren't necessarily
all that complicated a lot of times
they're simple actions but the the
difficulty of this part of the bot
doesn't really tell you the value this
one bot has saved hundreds of hours for
our development team for having to go
into these issues and tell them to run
CI so how do you set up your environment
to do these bots to offer these spots
locally this is a pretty github centric
in the way I describe it but it's likely
worth noting there's nothing github
specific about what we're doing here you
could change this events to not be
github events you could use Pro bot and
send it web hooks from somewhere else
all possibilities so the first thing we
do to support local development is start
a proxy this is so that way we can use
our local development system as the
target of the web hook that github
provides there's a service called Smee
we can use all you have to do to use
this particular proxy is go to smooth
out i/o click a button and it will give
you a slug Earl that you can then use to
route your issues to your events from
github too so we start by running our
proxy once we get that slug Earl and
this sets everything up for us I should
mention as possible you don't even need
to run this step but we found
environments that if you skip this
it might not properly configure and so
you run it once you only ever run this
the first time you set your machine up
and the next thing you do is you're an
NPM start like I said it's
basically just a regular node package
once you use Probot and it will direct
you to go to port 3000 in your machine
this is that way we can go ahead and set
up the github app you'll be presented
with the screen that looks like this
where you have to register your github
app you'll go through the github apps
creation process we'll give it a name
we'll configure permissions once we get
our under configuring permissions things
start to get a little bit harder to do
because we have to ask ourselves some
real questions what does this bot really
have to change about a repository and in
theory we could give it all access but
again back to risk we likely don't want
to do that so we're going to have to
start sort of thinking in the case of
the spot we're going to need right
access to the repository because we need
to add labels we're going to give it
permission to mess with pull requests
only and that will restrict it from
doing anything too crazy and once we've
done that we need to install the bot
into the repository there's a install
app button on the screen we're on for
permissions and you'll be presented with
a yellow box and where you'll have to
review your permissions so the
permissions here are being reviewed are
from the previous step and I point this
out because if you don't do this nothing
interesting will happen just sit here a
while it's an easy mistake to make
because you think well I've made a bot
and I've set permissions but you have to
do this step you also might have to do
this step again if you ever change the
permissions and that that's a gotcha
that's caught me I haven't given that
all the permissions that needed the
first time around and if you forget to
do that again it won't trigger on those
things until you come and do this so we
click on that link we can say alright
these permissions are safe I'm happy
with that we can install it on any
repository or all repositories in an org
something that I do is I create a
repository purely for testing it's not
important I can make PRS against it
branches whatever it'll be fine and I
target this repository with new bots
that way I can sort of test drive them
before putting them against anything
live so we set that permission up and we
can move along for running the bottom
to do this we need set a few environment
variables every github app comes with an
application ID it comes with the private
key and it comes with a secret for web
hooks these are pretty straightforward
to get the app ID will be at the top of
the app page then you can export it to
app ID the web hooks secret is a string
that you set so for demonstration
purposes in this case it's a pro bot
demo and then we need to configure
private keys at the bottom of the page
there's an area that you can generate
new secrets it'll automatically download
a JSON for you and as long as you put
the path to that it'll be able to
resolve this for you
so here we show a cells running NPM
start it's forwarding to speed out to
localhost 3000 and we're starting to get
these post requests coming through the
post requests are all the result of me
opening this PR they said it as a test
repo so you can see that I've updated
the readme a bunch and opened and
reopened a whole request and then we can
go over to Smee and start to look into
what events we're getting if we expand
one of those pull requests will see the
JSON payload and what it looks like
on a live repository you get a better
idea of what information our BOTS
receiving and how us how to respond to
it so this is handy for live debugging
and just ad hoc testing but it's also
useful for them taking these payloads
and turning them into unit tests that
are repeatable and so that's that's
where this tends to be most useful is
you can add hoc test how it works and
you can capture that and turn that into
a test you can run over and over again
and avoid regressing your BOTS so what
is the deployment stack for that look
like now that you can run it locally how
do we get that into somewhere that's not
running our development machine we use a
variety of services like I said we put
this on Google cloud functions we
ultimately use storage a thing called a
KMS key management service so let's talk
about a bit of those components the most
important bit is Google Cloud functions
we started on this just as a call-out
right away at the time we started this
github actions didn't exist
at this time if we started this again
that might have been an approach we
looked into but we already started this
for Google cloud functions and so it
doesn't really make much sense at this
point for us to go back Google cloud
functions take a web event any sort of
HTTP trigger and they can start
executing and so there are these little
on-demand actions which is a really good
fit for a bot they tend to be a good fit
for anything that doesn't have a lot of
state management and that's not being
called very frequently and most spots
aren't you know they're intermittently
called maybe just during business hours
and so this is a good application for
that and there's an existing Google
Cloud function handler that Probot
provides if you'd like to use this you
can install it from them we also wanted
to use a thing called KMS key management
system service and so the idea here was
that we didn't want to store any of the
secrets in the college function itself
there's a potential security risk in
using environment variables in the bot
as well just like there would be for a
CI system and so instead of using
environment variables we can inject
these things through the kms system
which ultimately stores them on Google
Cloud storage and then they're fetched
as they're needed and then immediately
piped into the commands so they're never
saw as an environment variable it would
be more difficult for someone to capture
those things and so the utility that's
released by Probot doesn't support this
so we ended up writing our own it is a
rather simple a bootstrapper so that
wasn't too much work but if this sounds
interesting to you that you would want
to use cloud functions and some of these
advanced more advanced features feel
free to reach out to me or come visit
any what the Google booth I'd like to
talk about it we haven't yet released
this to people it's only in our
repository but if there was a value is
something we could consider open
sourcing further so this is the reason
we use like I said it's a simple package
in our repository it is under active
development but if this interests you
please talk to me further we also use
the system called Google Cloud build and
this is what deploys our BOTS this
allows us to use the secrets that we're
storing as well as the deployment
pipeline no developer needs to manage
the publishing it just
self-publishers as we need so that's
that's good for us
but let's step away from that a bit and
get out of some of the google specifics
and just talk about if you were to
publish a single bot it's just something
like LOD functions what would that look
like it's going to look again like a lot
of node apps you've you've written
before we're gonna have a compilation
step all of our BOTS our typescript most
of our code base in fact is we're going
to make a target directory and copy some
things over to it and that's the build
step technically this target part isn't
necessary but it is a bit of a safety it
means that when we go to deploy we don't
deploy anything unnecessary we're only
going to deploy the things we most care
about for the bot not random artifacts
that happen to be in the repository for
publishing we provide a function name
and Google Cloud comes with a tool
called tree cloud and we can use that to
upload a function once we provide a
directory through here we're going to
provide it to use all the kms secrets
for us it's going to go through and
upload it for us through G cloud and
that that can be done with without cloud
build the reason we use cloud build
ultimately is we have more than one bot
and so it's nice to have a centralized
system for that and a pattern we can
follow so I hope this has helped you
understand a bit of how we do BOTS at
least for Google cloud client libraries
and has inspired you to embrace using
vos for your team from a lot of
gardening and allow you to do more
meaningful work I would say that any
test that's repeated often is a good
candidate for BOTS and virtually all
projects can benefit from using them I'd
also like to mention that all of our
bots are open sourced they're on github
but they can be looked at this is the
repository they exist at there's a
variety of instances of them and most
all of the examples I talked about our
bots that exist that we are using today
and I also wanted to take a moment to
thank the others that contributed to
this I am certainly not the only one
that has worked on this project a lot of
people have I wanted to take a moment to
thank them all for their efforts so
thank you all for having me
[Applause]